salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous le savez le Festival de Cannes
commence dans deux jours pour l'occasion
on va vous parler de films alors pour
les plus grands les plus longs ou les
plus chers non les films maudits ceux
dont le tournage a été le plus galère
Apocalypse Now l'exorciste et donc qui
chante des films où tu vas voir rien de
ses passer comme prévu les coulisses du
cinéma c'est ton truc et on va commencer
par un tournage complètement fou celui
d'Apocalypse Now
à
un tournage fou c'est vraiment long nous
sommes en 1975 à cette époque Coppola
allevant il est une réalisateur du
parrain 1 et 2 deux gros cartons
planétaires à Hollywood c'est le roi du
pétrole mais le nouveau film qu'il
prépare n'a rien à voir avec les
précédents c'est une adaptation du roman
au cœur des ténèbres de Joseph Conrad à
ceci près que l'intrigue est transposée
au cœur de la guerre du Vietnam dans les
années 60 le pitch du film est le
suivant c'est l'histoire du capitaine
Willard chargé par les services secrets
américains de remonter un fleuve jusqu'à
la jungle cambodgienne pour retrouver et
tuer le colonel américain Kurtz qui
serait devenu fou Coppola s'inspire d'un
slogan hippie Nirvana pour baptiser son
film Apocalypse Now et pour ce tournage
il négocie un très gros budget 16
millions de dollars ce qui lui permet de
tourner en décor réels aux Philippines
les paysages ressemblent beaucoup à ceux
du Vietnam pour le rôle de Kurtz
utilisateurs choisi de faire appel à
l'une des plus grandes stars du cinéma
mondial Marlon Brando Coppola le connaît
bien ils ont travaillé ensemble sur le
parrain pour le rôle principal celui de
willarde c'est plus compliqué il a pensé
à Steve McQueen Robert De Niro Robert
Redford Jack Nicholson mais tous
refusent de participer au film ça
commence très mal finalement copola mise
sur un acteur moins connu Harvey Keitel
après trois semaines de tournage le
réalisateur décide de jeter un oeil sur
les rushs
à la hauteur Coppola décide de le virer
et jette tout ce qu'il vient de tourner
à la poubelle allez on ne se démonte pas
Coppola propose le rôle à un autre
acteur Martin Chine le père de Charlie
Sheen cette fois c'est la bonne le
tournage peut reprendre mais le 19 mai
1976 deuxième douche froide c'est le cas
de le dire un typhon s'abat sur
l'archipel des Philippines et détruit
tout sur son passage les décors le
matériel tout est noyé sous la boue le
réalisateur frôle la faillite d'après
l'équipe de tournage il est devenu fou
complètement parano heureusement il
parvient à se reprendre on reconstruit
les décors en quelques semaines et le
tournage reprend une nouvelle fois mais
lorsque Brando débarque sur le plateau
le metteur en scène n'en croit pas ses
yeux l'acteur a pris 40 kilos pire
encore Coppola affirme que Brando n'a
pas préparé son rôle en amont
on se calme on respire à chaque problème
sa solution Brando s'enferme une semaine
pour travailler son personnage ok il
apprend son texte mais pour son poids
alors pour masquer son embonpoint on
décide de le filmer en gros plan et dans
la pénombre ce qui au final va donner un
vrai style au film bon là on se dit que
les ennuis sont terminées et bien pas si
vite Coppola n'est pas encore au bout de
ses peines le premier mars 1977 il doit
faire face à une nouvelle catastrophe
Martin she son acteur principal qui fait
son jogging comme tous les matins
s'effondre attaque cardiaque s'il meurt
le film est foutu il faut l'hospitaliser
en urgence à Manille la capitale des
Philippines un mois plus tard ouf Martin
Chine rétablit et de retour sur le
plateau et le 21 mai 1977 clap de fin le
film est dans la boîte le travail de
post-production peut enfin commencer oui
mais pour la production le film c'est un
naufrage le tournage devait durer six
semaines Jamy et au final il s'était
allé sur 16 mois en prime il explose le
budget il coûte 31 millions de dollars
au lieu des 16 prévues à l'origine vous
pourrez croire que cette catastrophe
s'arrête là pas du tout le montage
s'éternise lui aussi pendant deux ans si
bien qu'en 1979 lorsque le film est
sélectionné pour le festival de Cannes
il n'est pas terminé c'est donc une
oeuvre inachevée qui est présentée en
compétition officielle une première mais
surprise il reçoit la Palme d'or à
égalité avec un autre film le tambour de
volkerschland d'orf et il faut attendre
2019 soit 40 ans après la première
projection pour que le réalisateur soit
enfin satisfait de son montage avec sa
version définitive Apocalypse Now Final
Cut
ce chef-d'oeuvre n'est pas le premier à
avoir connu un tournage mouvementé cinq
ans avant le tournage de l'exorciste
l'histoire d'une petite fille possédée
par le diable a également marqué
l'histoire du cinéma
ce film de William Friedkin a
littéralement traumatisé les acteurs il
serait même à l'origine du décès de
plusieurs personnes
l'exorciste un enfer pour les acteurs le
récit des coulisses fait froid dans le
dos presque autant que le film lui-même
première difficulté pour William
fritzkin trouver des comédiens qui n'ont
pas peur de flirter avec Satan pendant
quelques mois pas simple j'ai une fonda
pressenti pour jouer la mère de la
petite fille est horrifiée par le
scénario elle refuse Audrey burn hésite
un peu mais elle finit aussi par
décliner finalement c'est une actrice
moins connue Hélène bursten qui accepte
à condition que son personnage ne
prononce pas la phrase je crois au
diable elle ne sait pas encore ce qu'il
l'attend enfin pour jouer le rôle de la
petite fille possédée le réalisateur
rencontre près de 500 actrices
finalement il choisit Linda Blair une
inconnue et là encore le tournage
commence mal des choses étranges sur ce
plateau par exemple un incendie
inexpliqué qui retarde le travail de six
semaines et puis il y a Jason Miller
l'acteur qui joue le prêtre il apprend
que son fils de 5 ans a été percuté par
une moto et qu'il est hospitalisée dans
un état très grave Miller s'écarte
quelques temps du tournage et quand il
revient il va mal il lui arrive de
s'effondrer sur le plateau en plein
tournage mais en croire l'équipe le
réalisateur William Fritz kidn n'a
aucune pitié au contraire il décide
d'utiliser ces moments de détresse pour
rendre les scènes encore plus vrai il
n'hésite pas non plus à gifler
violemment un de ses comédiens juste
avant de crier action pour que l'éclate
ses larmes soient plus convaincante le
comportement tyrannique du réalisateur
va plus loin encore lors d'une scène clé
ou la mère de la petite est projetée en
arrière contre un mur par le démon le
système de catapulte prévu à cet effet
se dérègle comme par hasard hélène
burten est effectivement catapulté mais
beaucoup plus violemment que prévu
est-ce un coup du diable ou de frites
qui lui-même toujours est-il que
l'actrice se blesse grièvement au dos et
se casse le coccyx elle hurle de douleur
mais le réalisateur est ravi il garde le
cri et jugent la scène absolument
parfaite n'épargne pas non plus la jeune
âgée de seulement 14 ans à l'époque du
tournage d'après certains récits frites
qui ne tient à ce que de réels vapeur
glacial sorte de la bouche de la jeune
fille pour un effet plus satanique alors
il fait littéralement congeler le
plateau en maintenant la température en
dessous de 0° avec un système d'air
conditionné frites qui n'est accusé de
violence mais il assume et ce n'est pas
tout plusieurs décès surviennent
étrangement dans l'entourage du film
l'un des acteurs Jack McGowan meurt
quelques jours après la sortie du film
le grand-père de Linda Blair fait aussi
partie de ce décompte macabre de même
qu'un veilleur de nuit et même un expert
des effets spéciaux a priori ces décès
liés à la vieillesse n'ont rien à voir
avec le film mais c'est du pain béni
pour William Friedkin et oui il comprend
vite que le récit des coulisses de son
film fait fureur auprès des journalistes
alors il en rajoute il affirme que Linda
Blair qui est doublée pour avoir une
voix démoniaque n'a en fait pas été
doublé d'après lui elle serait devenue
pendant le tournage il raconte aussi
qu'au montage des images
subliminales seraient apparues sur la
bobine d'autres récits affirment même
qu'un véritable tueur en série était
présent parmi les seconds rôles le
diable fait recette à sa sortie
l'exorciste connaît un succès fulgurant
c'est aujourd'hui l'un des films les
plus vues de l'histoire du cinéma et en
2021 William friedkins sort un
documentaire intitulé l'exorciste selon
William Friedkin où il revient en détail
sur ce making-of infernal la troisième
place de cette étonnant ponium on trouve
un autre cinéaste qui a tenté le diable
pour aller au bout de son film Éric
Gilliam en 1998 il se lance dans
l'adaptation de Don Quichotte de
Cervantes mais vous allez le voir lui
aussi va devoir faire face à des vents
contraires lorsque Terry Gilliam se
lance dans l'aventure ça fait plus de 10
ans qu'il a ce projet en tête donc il
chote c'est l'histoire d'un homme fou de
littérature de chevalerie qui va se
mettre en tête de traverser l'Espagne
pour sauver le monde en se battant
contre des moulins avant pour son film
prend quelques libertés avec le roman il
décide de mélanger deux époques hier et
aujourd'hui et de raconter l'histoire de
Toby un jeune publicitaire qui tourne un
spot en Espagne avec les personnages de
Cervantes d'un coup Toby se retrouve
projeté 4 siècles en arrière et fait la
connaissance du fameux Don Quichotte
pour son castingham a convaincu Johnny
Depp de jouer Toby le publicitaire
Vanessa Paradis les tranches le premier
rôle féminin pour jouer donc qui choque
le réalisateur tente un choix pour le
moins
inattendu celui de Jean Rochefort
l'acteur français âgé de 68 ans est un
passionné d'équitation et un très bon
cavalier ce rôle est une aubaine pour
lui car de nombreuses scènes se
déroulent à cheval au départ ce tournage
se présente donc sous les meilleurs
auspices sauf que côté budget c'est plus
compliqué Jany le réalisateur évalue le
coût de son film à 60 millions de
dollars et les studios américains seuls
capables d'une telle dépense ne le
suivent pas un film tiré d'un roman
espagnol du 17e siècle ne peut
intéresser que des studios européens le
réalisateur parvient malgré tout à
réunir l'argent mais à peine le tournage
commencé il apprend que le producteur
allemand fait marche arrière le budget
déjà serré et divisé par deux et ça se
sent les accessoires pour les costumes
sont de mauvaise qualité le matériel
arrive en retard comme les décors rien
ne va malgré tout Gilliam garde la foi
il mise tout sur son trio d'acteur
gagnant mais là encore rien ne va se
passer comme prévu pour tourner les
premières scènes à cheval avec Jean
Rochefort le metteur en scène a choisi
une réserve naturelle près de Madrid
sauf une fois sur place il découvre que
l'endroit est à deux pas d'une base
aérienne des hélicoptères survoltent en
permanence au lieu de tournage les
techniciens s'arrachent les cheveux le
bruit empêche la prise de son et le
lendemain c'est un torrent de grêle qui
emporte tout le matériel sur son passage
dans la région et les habitants n'ont
jamais vu ça
après cinq jours de pluie le soleil
réapparaît et le tournage peut reprendre
mais le pire reste à venir Jean
Rochefort ne dis rien mais son visage se
crispe et son corps se réduit quand il
grimpe sur son cheval il n'a pas osé en
parler à tes régulières mais il souffre
d'une hernie discale horriblement double
il doit rentrer en France pour consulter
son médecin couper Rochefort ne
reviendra jamais l'état de son dos ne
lui permet plus de monter à cheval le
tournage est annulé pour Liliane c'est
un échec monumental il racontera
l'histoire de ce rêve avorté dans un
documentaire intitulé lost in lamancha
je vous le conseille mais il ne renonce
pas pour autant à son film contre toute
attente en 2009 il annonce la reprise de
cette superproduction avec un casting
flamboy Robert Duval et Evan malgrégore
mais la malchance frappe encore les
financiers le lâchent une nouvelle fois
en 2014
rebelote Gilliam fait cette fois appel à
John Hurt et Jack O'Connell il obtient
les financements on y est presque mais
John heart découvre qu'il est atteint
d'un cancer juste avant le tournage
patatras finalement en 2017 alors que ce
film est déjà culte sans exister Terry
Gilliam surprend le monde entier cette
fois c'est du Louvre Jonathan Price est
donc qui chante Adam driver un carnet
Toby le film est prêt à sortir sauf
qu'au dernier moment un conflit sur les
droits avec son producteur par le Branco
menace encore la diffusion du film le
réalisateur à bout de nerf remporte
malgré tout cette bataille juridique et
le 19 mai 2018 le Festival de Cannes
projette enfin l'homme qui tu as donc
qui choque et je laisse le mot de la fin
à Lauren
a gagné sa bataille contre les moulins
avant moral de l'histoire les cinéastes
sont les dons qui chotent des temps
modernes merci Laurène je vous l'avais
bien dit que ces films étaient maudits
alors des histoires comme celle-ci on en
a plein de tiroirs alors si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à la
liker à laisser des commentaires et à
vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas
déjà fait allez à dimanche prochain
épisode épicurieux
[Musique]